la france premier pays européen en
nombre de chasseurs au total ils sont
1,2 million dans notre pays et forcément
c'est un électorat très courtisé pour la
présidentielle mais aussi très organisé
et les chasseurs sans les nommer
la chasse cette tradition française
valéry giscard d'estaing et georges
pompidou on était friand dans les années
70 le domaine de chambord et est le
terrain de jeu préféré les deux chefs
d'état sur les quatorze sanglier abattu
le président pompidou en inscrire quatre
à son actif tous linverse de françois
mitterrand qui détestait ça à partir des
années 80 le sujet devient clivant la
chasse et notamment dénoncé par les
écologistes ennemi juré des chasseurs à
l'image de dominique voynet candidate
des verts à la présidentielle de 1995 je
ne chasse pas je ne chasserait
probablement jamais et je me suis donné
pour objectif de défendre les droits des
non chasseurs contre les excès de la
chasse alors des chasseurs riposte ils
s'organisent font du lobbying auprès des
élus ils ont leur propre parti depuis
1989 chasse pêche nature et tradition
et en 2002 pour la présidentielle les
chasseurs vont même plus loin il décide
de lancer leur propre candidat à
l'elysée jean saint josse je crois qu'on
arrive à un point que la ruralité étant
délaissés au point où elle est libre
mais on se sent petit peu dans
l'obligation de le vouloir des fins de
ce territoire cinq ans plus tard pour la
présidentielle de 2007 frédéric nihous
représente le parti mais cette fois il
n'est pas le seul candidat à défendre
les chasseurs d'autres l'ont bien
compris les chasseurs c'est un électorat
important comme le candidat
souverainiste philippe de villiers venu
les draguer lors d'un forum consacré à
la chasse je salue les ruraux profond
pour oublier jean marie le pen le
candidat front national les armes de
guerre peuvent circuler sans contrainte
les champs contrôle dans les banlieues
mais les fusils de chasse eux font
l'objet de vin décrets et arrêtés pour
les règlements en 2012 les chasseurs
avaient apporté leur soutien à nicolas
sarkozy candidat ump puis en 2017 à
emmanuel macron candidats lrm pour la
présidentielle de 2000 22 willy schraen
président de la fédération nationale des
chasseurs a annoncé prendre position
pour emmanuel macron le président
sortant est proche du lobby des
chasseurs pendant son quinquennat il a
notamment diviser par deux le prix du
permis de chasse nationale
[Musique]